now it is time to put on my smart
glasses for the final thought Ben had a
good piece up on Daily wire today called
where does evil come from in it he
describes psychologist Roy Baumeister's
four categories of evil instrumentality
threatened egotism idealism and sadism
and he adds his own mental illness
what does evil look like what form does
evil take how does evil express itself
in the mind are important
psychological questions that emotionally
manipulative Democrat politicians
willfully ignore when they capitalize on
human tragedy to push largely
unconnected policy agendas but it's a
good question - where does evil come
from that question is not ultimately a
psychological problem it's a
philosophical problem and the answer to
that question lies at the heart of the
political debates that began seconds
after the news of the Las Vegas tragedy
were reported for utopians on the left
evil comes from bad public policy tweak
a few laws here give the government some
more power there and we'll be right back
in Paradise they say imagine all the
people you may say I'm a dreamer but I'm
not the only one the rest of us know
that this is nonsense that the
imagination of man's heart is evil from
his youth we are fallen and banished
from earthly paradise and wherever there
are men there will be evil no government
policy or agency can redeem mankind but
idealists persist in their delusion
because it's far nicer to delude
ourselves into thinking that a law can
eradicate all evil than it is to face
the grotesqueries that we glimpse in the
mirror on that i'm michael knowles this
is the michael nul show come back next
time we'll do it all again
[Music]
[Music]